some throwback thursday vegas style j.c
shows us more in this week's episode of
sin
city chronicles
it is time for this week's sin city
chronicles a weekly
look back at vegas history and
happenings and back in the 90s
many of us spent our weekday afternoons
watching this
what's going on carson daley here total
request live
moments away in march of 2000 carson
daly brought trl to las vegas
for mtv spring break 2000. highlights
included a performance from no doubt on
fremont street
plus an appearance from omar epps and
joey mcintyre
march 10 1991 unl defeated unlv defeated
fresno state to win the big
west tournament the rebels entered the
ncaa tournament
ranked number one with a record of 30-0
they lost to duke in the semifinals
let's relive
[Applause]
that loss also ended unlv's 45 game
winning
streak that dated back to the prior
season to stardust that was imploded on
march 13
2007. there it goes the hotel it was
open for 49 years
it was home to so many icons including
siegfried and roy in the 70s
george carlin andrew dice clay and wayne
newton
and in the movie casino the tangiers
hotel that was based on the stardust
hotel
march 10th 1995 the hard rock hotel
opened it was a star-studded weekend
celebrities in attendance included
george clooney nicholas cage pam
anderson
tommy lee halle berry jack nicholson and
kelsey grammer
and there were performances from bo
diddley weezer duran duran shirl crow
melissa etheridge billy idol
and the eagles the hard rock closed last
year
and will reopen as the virgin hotel
later this month
that's your sin city chronicles for the
second week of march